when I tend to order coat your home
I'm not going to go into a lot of
explanation today all you've got to do
all you have to do is think about how do
I get my right leg the other side of
this if you can do that anybody can tell
anybody
even if it's wrong
so it doesn't matter what you're doing
here even if all this upper body part is
wrong
even if this upper part's blocked as
long as I get this little foot the other
side of him so that's what I'm working
on I'm not sort of worried about him
blocking me up here and all I do is
shift one leg through the other
door he is difficult if you try and work
the bulk out
but it's not if you try and work the
lower part
you can see my
you've got to guess because I don't know
if it's the other side of your spot what
I do in this case because I've done it
so long but look this is what I've got
to do put it down front one's bent back
one straight I should change I change
and just keep your face out of the way
but that's all you've got to remember
these this shift shift your weight if
the leg only gets a little way because
you say I can't get it that way since
I'm I'm small I'm a short person then
that's that you've got to at least
expand and do your best
I mean he's taller than me isn't he so
you know you could say I'm sure
but um but the thing is you go as far as
you can as far as you can and then you
go
push off that one
okay